well you're watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the columnist for the article ali
mirage
and the uk economy reporter for
bloomberg lizzie burden
there they both are before we get to
them let's see what's on some of those
front pages
the observer leads with ministers vowing
to ensure trust in the bbc
is restored in the wake of the
controversy over how martin bush's
famous interview with princess diana was
obtained
the mirror hears from angry members of
michael jackson's family the late singer
was famously interviewed by mr bashir in
2003.
meanwhile the telegraph reports
scientists working for public health
england have found that
two doses of the fisa or astrazeneca
vaccines are highly effective in
guarding against the
indian covert variant it's also the
sunday people's big splash their
headline
vaccines do work on variants and that's
also the top story
for the mail on sunday there it is the
sunday express leaves on that story too
saying
we're on course for freedom day june
21st
and the big story for the sunday times
the allegation by the prime minister's
former chief advisor dominic cummings
that the government was
secretly pursuing a strategy of herd
immunity
against the virus last autumn
all right well we're joined tonight by
ali mirage and lizzie burton as
i was saying good evening to you thank
you so much
for joining us right let's start with
the times and
this interview um by martin bashir ali
we'll go to you first i mean
this is what everyone this is who
everyone wanted to hear from his first
in-depth thoughts really since that
report came out
ali what do you make of it well kimberly
this is the fight back from uh martin
beshear because we know that
uh earl spencer in the last day has uh
said that
uh he draws a direct line between the
interview that martin beshear
uh secured with his sister under false
pretenses
uh by forging those bank statements as
we know that made her feel paranoid and
agree to this interview
and her death two years later so that's
earl spencer's position
and he's also called for a police
investigation
into the mata bashir has come back and
basically said that he didn't make
uh diana do anything she didn't want to
do she wanted to talk to him and indeed
that they became
very good friends and you can see in the
times there that
um diana actually attended the birth
of bashir's third child and they were
exchanging letters and they became
very close that says maybe but um
bashir obviously is trying to deflect
blame from himself and
it may very well be the case that diana
would have given an interview anyway
what was not the case though was that he
had to procure that
under false presenters and make a very
vulnerable uh
woman in in a lot of uh in a difficult
position already
feel completely um at risk for her life
and paranoid about the those closest to
her
were betraying her so he didn't have to
do that at all i think the bbc's got
some
real questions to answer because in the
in the interview they say
he cannot quite bring himself to admit
that he wronged the princess
um lizzy i'll just read an accent i can
understand the motivation of earl
spencer's comments but
to channel the tragedy the difficult
relationship between the royal family
and the media purely onto my shoulders
feels a little unreasonable the
suggestion i am singularly responsible i
think is
unreasonable and unfair i mean lizzy
what do you make of what he said
yeah he seems to think that he's
redeemed himself since that interview he
says he was only 32
at the time he thinks he's redeemed
himself through his later work at the
bbc he can't seem to understand that
um you know part of the outrage is that
he was even given a second
chance at the bbc you know we've had
lord hall
stepping down from the national gallery
today um
you know partly because he gave bashar
that second
chance um you know yes he says that
diana was happy with the interview um
and but you know it it it is difficult
to
lay all the blame at beshear's feet all
the blame at the bbc's
be um you know there's clearly a wider
problem in journalism this was supposed
to be the scoop of the decade
um you know but you can't be having
scoops at any cost
um you know there's there's clearly a
problem with the fetishization of scoops
if people are going to this length
to get them because it was all about the
forge bank statements and we'll get
to the political pressure on the um on
the corporation
in a moment but it was about these
forged bank statements
in the interview he says listen i'd met
her before we presented these bank
statements to her but ali as you said it
was more than just showing her some
forged bank statement wasn't it
it was feeding into this sense of
paranoia
that her son spoke of
indeed and uh you know prince william
spoke
very eloquently and gave a very
heartfelt uh
account of himself himself of his view
of the whole matter
and actually he was very balanced in his
statement saying that
he thought that actually it led to the
breakdown of his parents
uh relationship in the end and also that
a public service broadcaster
it's a very important role to play in
society but should not be engaging in
these kinds of acts and that's something
that the bbc
has to um really look at very very
carefully i mean it's certainly the case
that
following prince charles his own
interview with jonathan dimbleby the
year before
it was likely that diana would want to
give her side of the story
but procuring it in this manner for a
public service broadcaster
is really beyond the pale and you've had
as lizzie has said
lord hall has stood down the question is
why did lord hall exonerate beshear
at the time of the initial investigation
which he carried out
and then hired him again in 2016
uh to be um covering religious affairs
and then indeed promoted him
to religious affairs editor and the
person who i think
is conspicuous by his absence in all
this is lord burt
who is the director general uh of the
bbc at the time we haven't heard
anything from lord burt on this matter
at all
and i do think it's important for him to
come forward and i also think it's
important for the bbc
to really clean up its culture we
already had the issue back in 2011 where
the program about jimmy savile was not
aired or news started he was pulled by
bbc management
and that created a complete not a fiasco
um so there is a cultural issue here
i don't think it should be blown out of
proportion that the bbc should be
disbanded i don't think that's sensible
but certainly there's an issue in terms
of when it comes to bashir
the short-term reward of having this
prized interview with diana
really did not outweigh the long-term
risk that not only his own reputation
but that of his employer and let's look
at the sunday telegraph because they say
bbc is one lapse
from bringing the whole house down um
and ali you mentioned jimmy savile there
it does seem you could argue
that they do have these
problems they then have very public
independent inquiries very public
apologies and then they seem to
get on quietly with exactly how they
were operating before
they've got a review a quarterly review
coming up on the charter do you think
that they can go into that without
a lot of change coming due to what's
happened lizzy
in a word no um after prince william's
statement yesterday it seems to really
have underlined
the severity of this situation um you
know
we've had lord mcalpine jimmy savile
rolf harris iraq um this
you know it really doesn't seem to be
the case that this could
uh be swept away without okay we'll do
be back we'll do better next time
um but you know it's really no surprise
that all the papers are piling on for
yet
another day on to the bbc about this you
know
they've been frustrated for years that
the bbc's
offering news on its website for free
and
you know competing with them um
especially to the detriment of the local
press
which you know arguably is to the
detriment of british democracy so
you know there's no surprise that the
papers are banning this fire for yet
another day
ministers are expected according to the
observer
their their headline we must act to
tackle appalling failures at bbc
warned ministers um and they're saying
that they are expected to be called to
the house of commons ministers
tomorrow to answer questions from mps
about the crisis ali that's going to be
very interesting isn't it excuse me
monday obviously this is the sunday
papers i think certainly
i mean i went to the supermarket today
to get some popcorn that'll be an
interesting
uh moment to to to watch was that for
eurovision or for this
well indeed it could be for both it
could be where everyone's watching us
not eurovision
of course um so look i think lord grade
um
again former director general um of the
bbc has come out
and said that there should be an
independent board
that deals with complaints at the bbc
uh so he's making that uh particular
point and that's going to be looked at
by ministers there's a midterm
review coming up next year for the bbc
before the
again ongoing discussions about the
bbc's funding model
and the renewal of its charter more
broadly and the bbc at the moment
is actually under new management so
there's tim davey
who's the new director general who seems
to be quite proactive and to be fair to
him
was very open in calling for this
investigation to be done
uh in the first place by lord dyson
which found this
and is seems to be wanting to you know
deal with things and get the bbc on the
right track
and also richard sharp who's the new
chairman who's very close to the
government
and clearly uh would want to get things
back on track for the bbc as well so
i do think there's a a glimmer of hope
here but it's obviously a very serious
situation that the bbc's in
and it really doesn't want to be picking
fights with the future king of england
okay ali lizzy we're going to take a
quick break grab a cuppa and we will be
back
because coming up promising news on the
effectiveness of
vaccines against the indian variant
we'll discuss that next
but this is all about helping other
people and
inspiring others um to take on to take
on challenges
um marx charity um is about providing
practical help
and physical challenges so for mark this
this this really is an opportunity i
mean
um well my my
personal speak um the um
it's aphasia i i can't speak
it's um it's uh the words it's
it's tricky but it's
you know it's a tricky place
so if if if we go back a little bit to
when mark
um first had his stroke um he was told
quite categorically
very early on that he would he would
never walk again
and it is this in this internal
determination that's
all part of commando training really
some of those uh
those words that you'll hear courage
determination cheerfulness under
adversity
what mark's trying to do here um is
inspire
others to an unrelenting pursuit of
recovery
and this is this is this is absolutely
what um
mark's charity is all about it's about
reaching out to others
and inspiring them to do things like
this
maybe if we just go back a little bit to
when mark um was going through his
recovery
um he went he went to headley court
which is the military rehabilitation
center
and it's my belief um from all the
conversations that i've had with mark
is this is really where the bower
foundation was was established um
mark mark will always remind me of a of
a gentleman who was in a bed next door
to him
um who who he said you know had
literally given
a given up hope and this is this is
about you know
mark saying do you know what please
please please don't give hope
don't give up hope come come with me i
can show you i can inspire you i can
sprinkle
some of that military pixie dust over
you
and help you with your recovery
this is the icing on the cake this is
this is the finale of your
last year's barrow a thousand to
actually get onto the summits
of these three mountains and just
demonstrate to people that
you know despite all of the challenges
you can actually
you know surpass it and you can you can
reach you know you can reach these
[Music]
limits
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
the safety ridge what's up for the ones
who want to know more welcome to the
all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free welcome back you're watching
the press preview with me now ali mirage
and lizzie burton hello to you both
again now this is exciting news um
lizzy let's start with the people
because
vaccines do work on variants it's a
public health
england study it broke today um just
tell us a bit more
yeah so it's really encouraging news
from government scientists that
two doses of the fisa or astrazeneca
jabs
are nearly as effective against the
variant that originated in india
as against the kent stream but you've
got to have two jobs
so you know it is great news we've had
all these horrible reports about people
in india having to have their eyeballs
removed
and because of the black fungus to do
with the um the variant that
started in india and you know the papers
are really encouraged about this because
the government said that it means
hopefully they won't have to delay the
reopening of the economy
on the 21st of june so we can hopefully
get
back to normal as planned um
you know the the the sunday express is
saying
we're on course for freedom day so
it's great news not just because of the
vaccine but also for the reopening
and valley the health secretary has said
that he's increasingly confident that we
are on track for the road map and it is
interesting because throughout all of
this
um we saw the easing of restrictions but
then with the indian variant it did kind
of feel that we were back before
christmas didn't it
but we have the vaccines now and this
proves
that we've got a two-pronged attack
i think that's right uh kimberly only
until a few days ago the prime minister
was being fairly
cautious uh about the the reopening i
mean he was always saying that he would
be driven by data not dates and the
the government's got four tests that
it's gotta meet um
on on hospitalization rates vaccine
rollouts etc
and new variants so these are all the
things it's got to take into account but
things are moving in the right direction
i mean 88
um effectiveness against indian variants
of pfizer
and over 60 of astrazeneca is excellent
uh so that's extremely encouraging and
uh boris johnson knows that uh in the
past he's been under
some pressure from elements of his back
benches and particularly the kobe
recovery group
who have really said that june 21 is his
effective
uh brexit day a bit like the one that
theresa may had to keep pushing back
and if he doesn't open on june the 21st
that could be the end of his premiership
which i think is a little bit
over egging it but but it is an
important day and i think things are
moving in the right direction i think
the r rate going up a little bit
but at the moment the hospitalization
rate is
is not going up which is the positive
thing isn't it and
the fact that the people who are sick
lizzie um
the ones who haven't they're eligible
for the vaccine but they just haven't
been getting it
yeah i mean we're they're lowering the
ages of who can actually get the vaccine
it's down to 32 now
uh funny and there are stories from the
us about uh
way innovative ways to encourage
americans to get the vaccine
about um pairing up with dating apps uh
with the government
to um a way to incentivize young people
could be
to show their vaccinated status on
tinder i don't know if that could work
here or if it'll even be suggested but
yeah it's a problem you can have the
most
successful vaccine you want but you need
people to take it
okay lizzie ali thank you so much